all right diana and sincere
yes you guys are from where originally
i'm from los angeles or is that from new
york new york
and uh how'd you guys meet
um i met since you're through my mom
i was walking the dog looking down here
she saw me it was that's all it took
yeah you're completely different people
yeah we're pretty different but you know
it's the um opposite mats i don't know
how that works but i say match
that's right no we match we match anyway
tell me about your childhoods diana you
grew up in l.a i grew up in new mexico i
was born in los angeles
i moved back to los angeles when i was
17. i'm 39.
how was your childhood
um i was sad most of the time i didn't
grow up with my mom being around
so i was
i accumulated a lot of anxiety and
depression i still suffer from
depression to this day
um
yeah so i mean i grew up with my
beautiful family and beautiful you know
skies of new mexico but my mom wasn't
around
and sometimes i'd be teased as a kid
like ha ha at least my mom's not in jail
and this and that and um i grew up in a
small town in new mexico called truth or
consequences
and um
yeah and uh i was really really dark
when i was younger it looked like i was
from india so i didn't look like the
normal like latin kid so kids would be
like at least i'm not black and just
little mean things like that like
in kindergarten so i'd go home crying
like why why are they saying things like
this to me and that kind of
um gave me
started my rough skin just how to
protect myself and
knew that kids were [ __ ] bullies and
you know little kids are mean we tease
each other for a lot of [ __ ] but you
know my mom would send me cool [ __ ] like
bmx bikes and a lot of things that i
wanted like a lot of
punk cds or tapes back in the day
um so i mean she was around but
not very much
but she is now so
and sincere
um grover queens
then also grandma lives in louisiana my
grandparents reared me
pretty much till i was about 13 14 then
i went back with my mom
um grandfather was at a navy colonel
grandmother was a
chef at the at the college um
northwestern university
um
pretty strict life you know
uh structured very very structured um
adhd so you know he had to teach me how
to do things a certain way to keep my
brain going but thank god he did it for
what he did but
i had a pretty good damn good childhood
be honest with you with the private
schools things of that nature
college played college ball um
[Music]
kind of had family got married
got divorced and
moved to california and things like that
then all fun started to happen
tell me what happened then well i moved
i moved to california after my divorce
um i have two kids say vaughn and
trinity
i came here with a business with a
marketing business
like yeah okay i'm going to the west
coast you know never been to the west
coast what i'm lying i used to come to
the west coast all the time as a kid
because my grandfather lives in oakland
um
this time i'm moving i'm like i'm gonna
take the business out here and yeah i'm
gonna make a million dollars and
when i got here
i was in sacramento
when we first got here we were in the
bay area and then
we went to sacramento and then it's like
if you go to los angeles we'll pay you
double
cool go to los angeles so when i went to
los angeles all calamity all hell set
loose
and
it's been a ride since but i'm still
here i'm breathing
were drugs a part of your life before
then no
no no i mean marijuana and east coast
you know crystal and stuff is uh taboo
he's like
you know um but so a lot of drugs growed
up you know what i mean but um never did
that was on the other side
and drugs started right around everyone
i got over here you know it's like
everything is pretty much freelance it's
pretty much hey you know try this try
that but um
and then i gotta hold this up called
crystal
and you know
we still rock to this day to a little
bit
but she don't control me though
diana actually you think
um
i dabbled in
kind of like weed my first drug was acid
at 13. i wasn't really into crystal or
any of that stuff um
when i moved to la um
i always wanted to try heroin and
one day i hooked up a friend with some
heroin and
i've been a heroin addict since 18. um
i've lost pretty much everything to it
um
about a year and a half ago it wasn't
you know i'd shoot a gram and um
i pretty much collapsed every vein in my
body and then my veins came back because
i don't shoot up anymore i end up
becoming a phlebotomist because i could
shoot up so well in pretty much every
vein of the body um i got into fentanyl
because it was much stronger
um i would spend so much money on heroin
and just not feel it and you know i
didn't want to get on fentanyl but
it was stronger and it didn't cost as
much and
um
you know heroin was different it it
really has wrapped itself around me like
a snake and didn't want to let me go
um fentanyl's a little different um
it's it's like kind of like crack heroin
like when you're sick you need it it
makes you when you're sick you need it
much sooner than you heroin
um i really do miss shooting heroin i
had stopped shooting heroin uh from 2013
to 2015.
um
and that was the longest time of my
sobriety it was two years i ran a heroin
anonymous group here in hollywood and i
went to another na meeting and i just
cut everyone out of my life who did
drugs i have a 10 year little boy his
name is cerulean
and
i lost him due to my drug addiction
you know luckily he's with his
grandmother
and he's been really well taken care of
um i haven't seen him in two and a half
years
and to this day um
it i still have major depression to her
it's very crippling to where there are
days i can't get out of bed because i
feel dead without my son
but
um
since i was a child i
you know was a cutter um
i still cut somewhat to this day but not
as intensely
um
unfortunately i didn't have anything
close today so i had to wear these
little shorts but you know i've got
scars all over my legs from
uh
dabbing and burning my legs on accident
and cutting but
um
you know heroin was really hard to put
down and i've been too many rehabs many
detoxes
and i finally found a way how to detox
myself i just i leave la i go to arizona
to my family
i take liquid g
xanax and i carry suboxone
and i've got in my own concoction
how to get off of it you know uh being
in a detox you meet other people
sometimes they get you kicked out
because they give you drugs and they go
snitch on you or sometimes you just get
yourself kicked out and i just learned
to be by myself and go in the middle of
nowhere where you can't get any fentanyl
really any heroin unless you know people
out in the middle of nowhere
um
it's better to just be alone with my
family and lock myself in a room for
five days and you know my grandmother
will already be accepted of what i'm
there for
um she knows about my lifestyle so does
my mom
pretty much my old family is you know i
come from a family of
alcoholics and
so addiction is nothing new to them but
you know i
i dabble in a really dark darker
addiction in my point of view
um
especially you know odin
um a year ago
i blacked out i'm riding my electric
scooter and i was found on vermont
avenue by the paramedics and was on life
support for four weeks and now
i suffer from memory loss and i go into
blackouts i'm still waiting on my pizza
i left uh our airbnb one day to go get a
pizza in echo park and i never returned
um
i
you know i don't i don't even know what
happened that day i just i remember
leaving um
sincere said i left my purse on the bed
i
i guess i was pretty high but
i
i don't remember anything i went to a
blackout um i have a psychiatrist i've
been seeing a therapist psychiatrist for
pretty much 30 years now
um
excuse me
i smashed out all of my teeth that
i spent 12 thousand dollars on root
canals um so i have a
hard time speaking sometimes to people
because
ever since i was a child i was looking
at people and look at the teeth
and
it's a big insecurity for me um
when i was 22 i got on america's next
top model
and got kicked off because i was on
heroin
and um
at the time i didn't care i was like
all right cool i did the week with tyra
banks and the whole americans like some
model thing i'm out of heroin they pay
me 30 bucks to be on the show which was
[ __ ] um i got on my 61 falcon and i
went straight to my job dealer um it
wasn't a big loss to me because i was
heroin i was dope sick
and you know i would have not
done heroin or had stopped at that time
i believe i could have went further with
you know my modeling career
um that i was always into fashion since
i was really young like seven years old
i got into vintage clothing
and have always been into like music
punk music and the more avant-garde
films and stuff like that
um
i've met a lot of great people in la
and uh
like i said when i was sober
um
several years ago i helped a lot of
people because
heroin anonymous really helped me um
just see the darker side obviously with
my addiction and helping others
just letting them know there's always
someone there when they were
alone kicking dope and no one else
wanted to help them or their family
didn't care or didn't want to care or if
they od'd and just came straight to the
meeting if they were loaded and came
straight to the meeting
they knew that they could be in a safe
place and no one would judge them as
opposed to like na people were a little
more judgmental you know and
so some friends from venice beach had
introduced me to h.a and
that was a good thing to connect with a
lot of people who were opiate addicts
because
we were
different from crystal meth users and
people who smoke pot and
obviously the alcoholic you know um
alcoholics will get dts and can
obviously die from getting sick
um other people didn't understand what
it was like to really kick dope you know
puking and shooting at the same time
um if you didn't have it
um
i never did anything sexual for drugs um
i would rather rob someone before i did
anything like sucking dick or [ __ ]
like
i'd rather rob
anything
and do that [ __ ] you know um
coming out to california i
stayed with my mom
who had served some prison time she's
tatted from
head to toe and she's really little
and she's a
very fair skin so when i was younger i'd
be like why am i dark and you're lighter
i come from a latin family that's
portuguese and spanish and mexican but
they're all very bare skinned
and so i always had a problem growing up
with darker skin until i was 14 and
everyone i started dating just loved my
skin and i ended up falling in love with
my skin
my skin color and i always make fun of
him like
you're half black half white and i'm
darker than you
um but you know um
i love sincere a lot and
it's we're trying to get off the streets
it's
it's really it's kind of [ __ ] up you
know we know a lot of people got housing
and we're still
we're about to get housing but
um our drug use definitely gets in the
way you know
how long have you been on the streets
um since uh 2018 when i lost my son um
i just decided that i wanted to
make sure that my mom was okay because
she has been homeless for a moment since
her wife had died in 2012
but you know when i came out to north
hollywood to meet up with my mom
she was okay um excuse me i smoked 20
cigarettes and fentanyl um
she has more friends than i do
she knows a lot of people there are
times i get on the train
and people will come up to me and be
like hey how smiley i'm like
excuse me do i know you and um like i
said i i get blackouts on memory loss
from my accident a year ago
um
so sometimes i remember meeting people
excuse me and sometimes they don't it's
like 50 first dates sometimes i wake up
with a visa with a video and let her
remember who she is
there are nights and days that i don't
remember
certain people i don't remember meeting
and it's
it's really kind of [ __ ] up because
you know uh one of my psychiatrists said
because the emotional
strain that i went through with losing
my son
and basically fighting for him for the
whole
at the time you know seven years that i
did i lost him when he was seven
it
it kind of [ __ ] with my borderline
personality disorder to where when i was
upset and angry i would cut myself and
now
because i haven't seen him for two and a
half years
my
my brain doesn't know how to deal with
emotional
like abuse or emotional strain so my
brain now blacks out and
he also um said that i now suffer from
disassociates of identity disorder which
is where i
will accumulate different personalities
so that i don't have to see
uh
daily streams or maybe have to go
through certain things in life that we
don't want to go through so i will turn
into like i'll just
kick into another personality and not
even know it yeah the personalities like
me either
it's really [ __ ] weird um
but
you know i had a woman come up to me
recently and she's like i'm so sorry for
disrespecting you last night on the
train i'm like excuse me like what did
you know what exactly did i say to you i
remember a moment of what i said around
the train she was speaking to my
boyfriend and kind of
doing it in a weird way and i was like
excuse me like you're getting a little
too close and
i think i said something to that point
and i greatly apologize to her when she
came up to me i was like i'm so sorry
that my behavior was erratic like that i
i would never hurt you like i would
never
do that i just i suffer from
blacking out and
you know when we fight sometimes we'll
argue really badly and
i'll just black out
and the whole night i won't remember
what the [ __ ] we did where i scored my
drugs
he will have been with me the whole
night and the next morning it's happened
twice i'll be like sincere where did we
go last night what happened
and sometimes i'm afraid to ask them
that because i'm like thinking about
what happened the previous night where
did i get my drugs who was i speaking to
like where did we go that's never
happened to me in my life i'm pretty
good at memorizing things and
navigationally i know where i'm at in
the city without a cell phone or a
compass and you know i grew up in new
mexico so i always
base my
location on the north star and um
oh here you can't really do that because
it's so bright with lights but
um
you know
[Laughter]
you know not having my son um
really [ __ ] up my life uh
i think a few years ago
if i if i didn't decide to move to
chicago with him on our own
and get a really nice condo that we
ended up living at
um
you know i wouldn't have lost him i
could have just stayed with my family in
arizona
uh my sister works for a bank i have a
little brother and my younger sister i'm
the oldest spiciest and smallest uh my
sister's about five nine and my
brother's my brother's about six one he
lives in
uh
i'll just say mississippi
in the south below
he's adorably gay and i love him and you
know he told me a few years ago when i
was in rehab on the phone for christmas
i thank you for being who you are and
dying your hair neon green at 12 because
i would have never been able to come out
and say that i was gay if it weren't for
you being who you are and so freely who
you are and
i was like wow thank you i you know i'm
never judgmental towards anyone and what
they do in life as long as they don't
hurt animals i'm vegan
um and children and
i
am really guilty
and hating myself a lot because
i had used around my son and never meant
to and um
you know i ended up losing him too
luckily you know he was always safe
always fed i took care of my son very
well
but you know uh i have an ugly addiction
that's been eating me up way before i
had him
and um i never wanted children because i
knew i was very selfish
um he was planned when i was with my
ex-fiance his father
and um
i was on methadone when i was pregnant
and
about a year after he was born somewhere
down the line i just relapsed on
morphine
while his dad was creating chaos at home
and
you know children family services saw
that and had taken our son from his
father
and then eventually took him from me and
for
seven eight years i had bought every
[ __ ] day to stay off heroin go to
rehabs go to aaa meetings
i got him back
for two years
and um
lost him again and
you know it's hard to cry because i've
accepted that he's okay and he's
he goes to school and i i um
i always keep in touch with one of his
foster ex-foster parents she was like a
second mom to him you know when i had
him his father was bisexual so he when
we broke up he had gay lovers and all of
his people in his rehab
would you know make sure my son was okay
because they knew that if anything
happened to my son i would [ __ ] kill
them um my son is number one to me
and the irony of that is that i can't
stop
excuse me i can't stop
doing fentanyl i can't stop doing
opiates
and someone you know on the other side
of the camera is gonna wonder like you
love your kids so much why can't you
stop doing this people don't realize
addiction
is a brain disorder
um
it's a lot of dialectical behavioral
therapy cognitive behavioral therapy
and self-care in order to get away
from self-harm you know even for the
alcoholic for the crystal meth addict
for
anyone else who just delves in drugs um
i also take alprazolium which is known
as xanax through my psychiatrist
um
at points
i have abused it because
i get [ __ ] really angry and i figure
if i just knock out i won't cut myself
and i won't beat the [ __ ] out of the
person who pissed me off or throw a rock
through their window like i do some
crazy [ __ ] [ __ ]
um for being 100 pounds that i am like
i'll wake up and you know since here
will be like what the [ __ ] you know why
did you do this i don't know i was mad
i realized that i don't need to explain
[ __ ] to anyone you know but myself if i
end up in jail i'll know that i [ __ ]
up i really
try not to go to jail
um i got a possession of heroin charge
in 2009 before my son was born or before
i had him
luckily that was dropped to a
misdemeanor because i wanted to go to
school to be a nurse
i'm now a phlebotomist
being in the hospital a year ago almost
a year and three months ago uh for four
weeks on life support being strapped
down to the bed not knowing where i was
made me not want to be a nurse anymore
um
i really really want to overcome my
addiction and work with disabled
children if i can
um
and or with animals you know um
i used to get really good grades in
school a's and b's
um
you know i went to college when i got
sober got my son back when i got sober
when i get sober i can [ __ ] do
anything
um
when i'm doing heroin or fentanyl
mixed with you know the xanax that keeps
me
uh level to not flipping the [ __ ] out uh
you should take lithium that [ __ ]
doesn't work
um i take xanax because it really calms
me down
um most people would just be like nah
you're addicted to it you're barred out
i'd be like shut the [ __ ] up you're just
jealous because you gotta take the pig
bars i don't
um
it really does help if it were an issue
i wouldn't take it anymore knocks me out
for a week it makes him very angry if he
does an accidental touch of an opiate he
gets very mean very different person
when he touches
like sedatives and opiates is there
what's the hardest part of
living on the streets with a partner
always wondering where where that
partner is
are they okay because a lot of times
when lose track of each other and i have
to find her
and i find her don't get i'll go turn
over every
nook and cranny in la to find her
uh they know i'm crazy so
they don't really bother me too much um
that's the hardest part just making sure
she's okay and making sure that myself's
okay at the same time because you know
i'm a big guy so everybody wants to
poke the bear till the bear gets you
know get started and it's like oh what
the hell's going on
but other than that i mean that's the
hardest part making sure she's okay are
you guys hopeful that you're you'll get
clean
yeah i mean
my thing i'm different on crystal than
most people because i have adhd so i
used to take adderall all the time so
it's pretty much the same thing i mean
like
like without it i'm a nut you know what
i mean like but with it it just makes me
focus and calm what happens when you
don't take it i get real erratic uh
you know i do multiple things at one
time which i'm good at you know um
i don't know what's the bad part he
doesn't think that you know shooting up
crystal is an addiction
it's a severe addiction that he has
once a day twice okay maybe you know
whatever he's [ __ ] up his veins
already and crystal meth doesn't usually
[ __ ] up someone's veins as as fast as
heroin does it's heroin is more acidic
so it eats up the veins a lot faster
that's cause i miss a lot but you know
he's very uh stubborn and most of the
time i'll help him
not buck up his veins and collapse them
any more than they are he's got swollen
hands swollen arms um you know sometimes
i'll get mad and leave for five days and
be like you don't treat me this way if
you do i will [ __ ] be gone and then
when i come back and you'll be like
where the [ __ ] have you been i'll be
like
you've learned your lesson kind of like
a child you go to your room for you know
uh time out and it's not time out with
him it's just like if you treat me a
certain way that i say i i don't find
acceptable i'm leaving
you know and i've almost left
really left
about a week and a half ago
um i go to the park i play my mom
and um she was okay and we go use the
bathroom like a three minute walk
about six minutes later her girlfriend's
pounding on the door i think your mom is
oding i run across the park
to my mom's tent and she's lying in her
tent blue um
strangely not her idiot girlfriend sorry
evelyn and idiot friend didn't go across
the street to the fire department to be
like this person's not breathing can you
help us
i always carry narcan that day i didn't
[ __ ] have it anywhere i'm sitting
there looking at my mom who's blue i was
like [ __ ] i've lost my mom
um
i don't have narcan i'm screaming like
the first time i've ever resuscitated
someone and flipped out
because i really thought i was gonna
lose her
um
you know
narcan's a good [ __ ] thing to have
you know um
she was [ __ ] dead i was like what the
[ __ ] you know like surely you need you
you know grandma and you and she started
blinking her eyes on is giving her mouth
to mouth and most of the time when i'm
bringing someone back i always call
common collective the three things you
need to do to [ __ ] save someone's
life
and i just [ __ ] lost it you know and
uh paramedic had ran over by himself
they didn't have enough time to get
their their vehicle to bring the whole
crew he ran over brought some narcan
gave her two doses and her life was
coming back
and you write that in there that she was
momentarily going to be okay
she's a stubborn
uh
woman
and um
i can see the
the stress that i put on my family
the stress that i would put on my son
um
and my mom when i would od you know i'm
gonna stress
what does your family think of your
lifestyle currently family doesn't know
about my lifestyle my family's in the
east coast i'm here by myself no you
have me well you know what she you know
but i mean like the immediate family
like you know the other side of them
this is my family here's what i got well
i have a family in the bay area too
but
ever since i became
homeless i like to say dressless and
things of that nature um i kind of like
lost little touch with my mom
because my family don't understand that
you know that's awful what homeless what
what is what is that you know like uh
suddenly you're not doing something
right you know or um you just show more
effort or that but it's nothing
coming from a family was structured
always had
anything everything i wanted um money
whatever um
it's totally topsy-turvy i mean it's
like
the way it happened to me everything was
taken away just like this so
when it happened i mean i've never had
to go to a church and ask someone to
take a shower because you're
filthy um
having to find a way to make
make a way to get something to eat you
know things that each other use a
bathroom like a normal [ __ ] support
yourself
how do you guys support yourself
well i sell drugs you know i mean um
i'm very
crafty at what i do you know what i mean
so i don't have any records or anything
like that it's just something
i boost stores uh
i get you know i steal whatever i can to
go sell it over to
uh you know in macarthur park or
downtown l.a
um like i said i've never sworn my ass
i'll sell uh i'll sell someone's soul
before i do that [ __ ] oh yeah
you know you got a dog um
you guys have friends
i don't have any friends
i tell her nobody's my friend exactly
he's always said no one's your friend
everybody has a terrier motive when it
comes to certain things and she's a
beautiful girl she's a beautiful girl
that's what i tell her she's like i'm
like nobody's your friend either they
want this so they want another nobody
gives you nothing for free that's pretty
truly the same with you
but i'm
i'm pretty much aware of i'm the watcher
i watch everything i mean there are
people though that i do care about you
know there's people out on the streets
that are also homeless uh other petty
heads as what i call them who get high
and betty
um people who don't hate it with a
passion and people who don't do petty
but they may use drugs or just people
that i know
um that i do care about they may not be
my best friend
but i care about them if they were to
die be [ __ ] i'd be upset you know
um he says no one is my friend because
of ulterior motives but there is emotion
there you know you you know some people
like if you if you're human you care
about other people
though if you're not a sociopath you
care about other people at least i'm not
a sociopath well call me what you want
i'm just saying this like
i mean when i feel like a person do
anything at any given moment yeah but
you've gotten upset when you've heard
certain people have died yeah i'm not a
monster you know i am a human i mean
like there are other humans are
humanoids out here but i mean but i've
learned to
pretty much just cut everything off and
i really get emotionless sometimes when
i get the way it's kind of
you know how that goes i mean it's just
what's your biggest regret
regret so i really don't look at things
as regret because everything is a
learning curve my grandfather told me
that because
you put yourself in a spiral if you go
that way and if you if you lose faith
and hope
you have nothing left so
if you
get down and out on all situational
aspects of things you're [ __ ]
i mean you gotta look at it like okay i
learned this but why did i have to learn
this r i mean the way i used to be
republican you know things of that
nature i would have never met the people
that i met
here if i would have stayed in that same
state of mind
um i would have never got a different
learning process of
certain avenues of life if i would have
stayed on this side so i got both
both of them together so i could roll it
together and make it work let's not make
it work here i mean like everybody they
wouldn't know we were homeless from
today or tomorrow you know i get people
coming to me and say you know i'm so
sick of these homeless people what do
you think about that i'll look at him
i'm like well
what's your biggest peep
and we try not to let people know where
we sleep because we just don't want
people to hurt us in any way
and people are
deceitful and ugly out there you know
like
uh they can be not always but we just
don't like we like to be very private so
being homeless is also kind of very
uncomfortable um when it first happened
to me i was distraught i mean i felt
like
it's just a shitty feeling of like oh
[ __ ] i'm waking up and i'm sleeping near
a lot of people and sometimes i'm very
anti-social agoraphobic and i don't feel
like dealing with people and i have to
wake up and it's like
i can't live like this like i need to
get the [ __ ] out of here kelly took my 7
45 i came out here you know with my
business and stuff and then they took my
car and that was my that was my
place of home that was everything and
then when i got taken it was like wow
i'm really out here you know it's like
but i met some people on the streets
anyway
you know they were living on the thing
called event where it blows up hot air
at night so it keeps you warm things of
that nature and i met a lot of
characters there but i met a lot of good
family there as well so when i say i
don't have friends if i don't have
family i don't have anything so
um they told me the ins and outs and
then you know me growing up in the
streets here and there and you know
street savvy put it all together and you
know that deluxe swag you know the east
coast swag you know we make it work you
know what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in your
lives
most important lesson
um
never give up uh
no matter how [ __ ] up things are you
know
i've
i've been suicidal at times i've tried
to commit suicide
uh luckily i
never
you know luckily never really did happen
um
but
i just i try not to give up um
even though like i never feel like i'm
gonna see my son again or i'm never
gonna have a small family to where i can
be sober
and live how i need to live in order to
take care of my message the main thing
though is really the monotony
because you can get caught up in like i
call it groundhog day
it's like the same thing every day every
day every day and every day and that
would drive a person crazy most people
stay on the same routine they do this
this and this this they do this this
then they do it every day
they'll end up setting this little
concert of maybe three mile radius
so we make sure we stay out of that you
know i mean so
a lot of people think the same we think
differently like they will stay here i
gotta go over here let's go to the beach
let's go do this change seniors for your
brain go like and do things other people
would do museums
library um still read books we listen to
a lot of music we fight over our music
our headphones our phones to listen to
music yeah we're like brother and sister
sometimes i also i'll tell people yeah
that's my brother [ __ ] yeah i'm joking
like
really dark sense of humor so sometimes
people can
you know jive with me and sometimes
people can't i don't give a [ __ ] if they
can't uh if they don't want to be my
friend or be in my life they don't have
to um i don't care if someone likes me
as long as i know that i have love for
myself love for my son and the next
thing i need to do is get [ __ ] sober
and get my [ __ ] together so that i can
be
like i guess a normal member of society
in history
because i come from i come from
corporate america so it's like
everybody corporate has their own thing
you know doing cocaine or whatever
whatever they're just you know whatever
but
people are the same they're all
not [ __ ]
all jokes aside i mean
from the ceo to the cfo to the
and i hate to even put it in that
spectrum of to the janitor or whatever
i used to um they all got their own
thing and they just keep it hidden i
forgot see you'll probably pushing more
coke than anybody in the whole america
you know i mean so he's doing that i
forgot yeah
but he's okay because he's you know but
close those doors he's the same guy that
has dirt all over him and
[ __ ] on him and same thing they're the
same person
except one just could afford to say
oh i use the bathroom myself i can go to
the restroom and clean up this one just
can't get to that spot or he gets [ __ ]
up before he gets there forgets that
he's
whatever got to add that uh i was a
dominatrix since i was 18.
really
yeah and that's how i was supporting my
heroin addiction um so when he says you
know that ceos and so and so have major
addictions
i'd have a lot of clients that would
come into the dungeon that i worked at
in west la
um
that you wouldn't [ __ ] believe had
addictions that were also naughty um
but some of the guys who come in with uh
crystal you want someone like i don't do
that but shut the [ __ ] up and bend over
so i could smack your ass like
a ceo comes and put a diaper on because
he doesn't want to judges lawyers
doctors you [ __ ] name it addiction
does not discriminate
um and they have nasty fetishes too i
mean this weird-ass people
shoot them a chance to make me feel
inferior i never don't know
but i did burn someone's [ __ ] with
cigarettes i did put out cigarettes in
his [ __ ] this is uh in my younger
days um
i haven't had anyone someone's as crazy
as that seeing most of my clients were
mostly foot fetishes
um
you know uh being
homeless and [ __ ] up my teeth a year
ago i haven't really done anything with
any clients and being with him he's not
comfortable with it
i you know i don't understand why might
just be my security guard and watch over
me why beat this person's ass and we'll
have money like yeah i'm not going to
that world you know he was like come on
i'll be like it's not like i'm [ __ ]
them or doing something inappropriate
with them
my baby's my baby i don't share with
nothing you know i mean it's just that
simple you call himself he doesn't know
how brutal i get with these people
because they pay for it and they want it
it's a different side of me being brutal
that's probably what it
is other side i put on my asian
provocateur lingerie before i lost it
recently uh
get really adorable
i want to put that on i said everybody
was building this [ __ ] you know he's
like ah can't wait no you know being
homeless i can't have any of that [ __ ]
because if i have it i'll get back to my
spot it'll be stolen you know when i
first started staying with him under
this
crazy part of the wash and uh
studio city was really [ __ ] scary um
people were still all mine if you don't
believe in god people you better believe
in god let's just put it that way well
you better believe in yourself she's
crazy i mean it's crazy i've seen some
things that
make your head blow this
i i've walked out of our spot in the
middle of the night onto the jogging
path and there'd be the wall of the
bridge and i should you not
uh in the middle night you know i'm not
loaded asleep having to get up and pee
i'd be like holy [ __ ] sincere like i'm
scared like come out here right now he's
like what if it's coyote who cares i'm
not afraid of wildlife i was afraid of
what i saw out there i walked out one
night and i [ __ ] you know i saw a
silhouette
of a [ __ ] spirit walking like a
[ __ ]
night of living dead i was like what the
[ __ ] dude like i'm not high
what is going on down here
it was a different world down there
where we've heard stories where uh
you're in the movie businesses
and killed a lot of mexicans in the
1930s and there were souls down there of
what he could see were both clairvoyant
in really weird ways um there were
satanic cults over there uh living under
that bridge we would see all these
million dollar billion dollar homes on
the hill and no one lived in these homes
up in studio city you don't want to go
there
real drugs all right
thank you so much you guys are
interested thank you very much
you